- Okay, this is my
first solo cooking demo.
I'm not gonna lie, I'm a
little nervous and excited,
but you know what, when
everything is calm and normal,
it means you've done it.
A healthy amount of fear is good.
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
What I wanted to cook for you guys today
is a pasta that is really
near and dear to me.
I could eat pasta every
single day of my life.
I have the metabolism of a sloth
who's asleep at the switch.
So unfortunately I cannot.
I love food, but what I've tried to do,
'cause I've been on a
wrecking ball pendulum
swinging back and forth, heavy,
thin, heavy, thin for me.
Everybody's body is different.
There is no diet, one size fits all.
And I also think that I've
tried to educate myself
to make healthy alternatives
of dishes I love.
Because when I was doing
the chicken and broccoli
type of diet with
working out all the time,
here's what happened.
I would go off the rails,
and then my pendulum would
swing all the way that way.
I've tried to find foods that actually
are just like the foods I love,
but very healthy versions of them.
I'm gonna make a spaghetti
today that's actually made
with, secret ingredient, chickpeas.
This pasta has changed my life,
and the truth is the way we digest food
is a lot of gluten-free and
rice alternatives to pasta
are a little inflammatory.
With this sauce, this
is just a simple sauce.
And I always wanted to be that kind of guy
who made simple sauces at home,
but I'm not like sexy in the kitchen.
I'm a little bird brained.
But this, if I can do it,
trust me, anyone can do it.
I also love cooking solo.
I love when recipes give
the right ratios for that.
If you go on our website,
you're going to be able to
get this for four to six,
but also one to two.
Jose Andres is on the show.
And he said, throw your
garlic in with the peel on.
And that way it won't burn.
Turns out, he's Jose Andres for a reason.
I've been doing it now,
and it has changed my game.
All right, so we're
going to get this going.
And when your oil is sort of sizzling,
you're going to take cherry tomatoes.
The longest thing honestly--
(tomatoes sizzling)
(audience cheering)
Yeah!
Oh, I told Jose Andres, I'm
also turning my heat down.
Okay. Calm down.
But longest thing that actually takes here
is cutting the cherry tomatoes.
This whole sauce should take 10 minutes.
I love layering.
This pasta can also be
made as fresh as you want,
or it can be made as a
complete pantry dish.
All you have to do is
take your dried spices.
I've got cherry tomatoes, basil, salt.
Now, my secret tip is I
love a little harissa paste.
It's a Tunisian spice.
And I do sort of like Lima
bean-size things in there.
And it adds this nice smoky, spicy.
I don't have a thing.
All right, I'm going right in here.
And literally this is it.
If you have dried herbs,
you can do oregano, parsley.
You could even do chopped
tomatoes in a can.
This can really be a staple
anytime that you want it.
I'm also going to do
a little tomato paste.
This, again, little Lima
bean-size dollops right in there.
And then you're just going
to keep cooking it down.
And eventually the cherry
tomatoes will just break open,
but they'll remain intact enough.
And you're going to have what
looks like a restaurant dish.
And like I said, if I can do
this, anybody can do this.
Another thing that's
really great about this.
If you would like to add
meatballs, go for it.
Because the way digestion works is that
it doesn't process meat,
proteins, and grains very well.
But because this is a chickpea flour,
your stomach welcomes proteins with it.
I also love to rock a
little digestive enzymes.
You can find these in any
health foods store or grocery.
Yeah, it just aids with digestion.
And since I started eating this way,
I've actually maintained the same weight.
And that is my secret.
I have found a way to have
pleasure in the kitchen,
and my body is happy
and it's responding with something
that feels really good and empowering.
And I'm not deprived.
I'm totally enjoying myself.
Shout out to The Pasta Queen, my friend,
who's a maven on Tik Tok.
She says to take your ladle
to get the ultimate in bird's nest.
And it really works.
Look at this.
If this was a bowl, it's perfect.
So shout out to her.
Ta-da! All right, I'm going to taste it.
I hope that you guys
have enjoyed the show.
Oh, beauty shot.
Oh, god, I already messed
up the beauty shot.
Well,
(audience cheering)
I hope that you take all the goodness
that we're feeling here with you
throughout the rest of your day.
That's what we're really here for
is to just spread good
energy and good cheer
and enjoy life and find what
all the things that are worth
just being human for.
Thank you very much for joining us today.
(upbeat music)